maryline benzema bonjour monsieur caruge
bonjour tous les martiniquais qui nous
écoutent ce matin alors vous êtes
également vice présidente du comité
martiniquais du tourisme on va commencer
par là puisque il ya quelques jours
encore un notamment dans un courrier qui
date de ce mois de mai 2018 le 12 mai
2010huit vous persistiez et signé
plusieurs signataires membre du conseil
d'administration du cnt on n'a pas tous
les citer mais enfin parmi eux il y à
jean-philippe ni lors gène larcher les
conseillères territoriales wistel aurait
dîné là ou encore donc jean marcel
marrant vous reprochez à nouveau à la
présidente de du comité martiniquais du
tourisme karine rousseau nous vous aviez
un certain nombre de griefs et notamment
vous déplorez un peu sa stratégie de
gestion
on en est où aujourd'hui en cette fin de
mois de mai ce que les choses se sont
apaisées
ce ne sont pas forcément des griefs ce
sont des demandes légitimes des
administrateurs qui siègent au comité
martiniquais du tourisme nous avons un
certain nombre de questions qui jusqu'à
ce jour restent sans réponse monsieur
marc en arrêter un redemander à la
présidente madame rousseau certain
nombre de réponses que nous attendons
toujours
alors apaisé nous ne sommes pas dans une
dans une guerre avec la présidente
simplement nous voulons avoir des
réponses conflit comme ce n'est pas
inconvenant ce sont des demandes et que
tant que nous n'aurons pas assez le
monde nous demanderons et nous
continuerons légitimement a demandé des
réponses
nous ne pouvons pas être en charge d'un
organisme je rappelle quand même que je
suis la première vice présidente et que
je gère ce cnt depuis 2004 je n'ai
jamais connu une telle opacité
donc c'est simplement ça nous demandons
une une gouvernance plus collégiale
alors je veux pas nourrir le canton que
c'est pas ça du tout mais quand même je
peux pas vous dire je peux pas vous
laisser dire non plus bien sûr car
c'était un camp c'est tout à fait
conséquents par exemple dans ce courrier
du 12 mai il est il y à cette formule
laban honnêteté dans toute sa splendeur
vous adressons donc à madame karine
rousseau s'est allié pour que je vais là
oui c'est à dire que s'il est question a
été posée quand je rendais à trouver
neuf jours n'étaient pas dans le
contexte d'accord simplement comme adam
mousseau dit que monsieur ni l'or a
agressé monsieur yan monplaisir c'est
faux c'est tout à fait le contraire
par ailleurs au début de ce conseil
d'administration monsieur yan monplaisir
qui a été le plus virulent n'était pas
présent donc d'office quand on traite un
autre administrateur la personne
monsieur jean marcel marrant devenir
s'engraisser c'est inadmissible voilà
c'est ça quand on parle de malhonnêteté
on ne parle pas de de cacher le budget
ou autre chose
on parle de ceux de cette phrase il faut
savoir quand on annonce que l'on va à la
presse faut savoir qu'est ce que l'on
dit exactement à la presse donc je
déplore cette situation est à nouveau ce
manque de discernement
alors pour pour conclure ce courrier se
termine sur une invite à la présidente
du comité martiniquais du tourisme à se
montrer à l'avenir plus respectueuse des
règles de fonctionnement
la fel respectueuse aussi des deniers
publics de l'ensemble des employés
membres du conseil d'administration du
cnt vous précisez qui autant que vous
souhaite la réussite du tourisme
martiniquais alors au nom de cette
réussite du tourisme martiniquais est ce
que les choses vont s'arranger est-ce
que depuis d'ailleurs ce courrier
du 12 mai vous avez eu des contacts avec
madame rousseau est ce que vous vous
parlez est ce que vous voyez dans ce pas
parce qu'on y pense pas qu'ils vont se
dérouler les prochaines semaines on se
parle ailleurs bureau autre bulle entre
temps on a eu un bureau mais nous
restons toujours dans l'attenté de nos
réponses mais nous sommes là justement
pour faire progresser et nous tenons
sous votre chaîne où la présidente a dit
qu'elle promet plus de collaboration
c'est tout simplement ce que nous
demandons bon et bien on va passer alors
vous êtes en charge également des fonds
européens
voilà cette fois à la collectivité
territoriale de martinique alors là
aussi il ya un débat on va appeler ça
comme ça un débat un pour envenimer les
choses entre l'ancienne majorité au
conseil régional aujourd'hui
l'opposition
pour ce premier mandat de la
collectivité territoriale
un débat autour des fonds européens et
donc du programme opérationnel
chacun se renvoie la balle et puis
surtout l'ancienne majorité au pmn vous
reproche d'avoir détruit un outil qu'ils
avaient mis en place et c'est ce qui
fait que finalement les fonds européens
ont du mal à être mobilisé en tout cas
rapidement ce qu'on va retenir c'est
qu'aujourd'hui à 80 80 agents de la
collectivité qui gère les fonds
européens
on ne peut pas demander une
responsabilité après la donner à l'état
pour la faire gérer ce qu'elle ferait de
marie jeanne a fait comme nous sommes
arrivés en 2015 on a construit un outil
au coeur de la collectivité
est ce qu'il faut retenir parce que j'ai
fait excusez moi je promenais l'ancien
outil le glp martinique europerformance
qu'est-ce qu'il avait qu'est ce que vous
lui reprochez parce qu'il était d'abord
géré par l'état ces années que nous
n'avions pas les clefs de décision alors
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons les clés de
décision d'accor ce qu'il faut retenir
ce dossier c'est que nous avons fini
d'étudier et de porter à la connaissance
de l'ensemble des porteurs de projet
2016 2017 tous les dossiers ont été
budgétisés
c'est ce qu'il faut retenir entre nous
nous sommes arrivés à la collectivité
quand décembre 2015
même si le p o de 2014 de mi 2014 2020
mais aussi le programme opérationnel
excusez-moi programme opérationnel de
1000 2000 2014 2014 2020 il a été
effectivement mis en place qu'à partir
de 2016 parce qu'on sait que fin 2015
c'était le début parce que quand bien
même le programme sort il y a également
à le mettre en oeuvre ce que nous avons
fait c'est qu'il y avait des dossiers en
portefeuille en attente et je rends un
hommage appuyé aux administratifs qui
ont mis les bouchées doubles pour
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes en a étudié
les dossiers de 2018 donc tout le retard
de 2014 2015 2016 2017 a été résorbé
c'est ça qu'il faut retenir et un
dossier de fond européenne n'est pas un
dossier de subvention simple il est
compliqué il ya beaucoup de va et vient
entre la collectivité administratif et
le porteur de projet et surtout ceux qui
sont à même de billets monter leur
projet savent le faire et c'est toujours
au niveau de l'agriculture
donc il il est important que je dise à
tous les porteurs de projets autres que
l'agriculture de se rapprocher les
services de la ctm et seront aidés par
les administratifs pour monter leur
dossier à propos de financements
européens
là encore c'est récent 1 c'est le maire
de fort de france
didier laguerre a posté un tweet datant
du xii maintien c'est la même tactique
que le courrier qu'elle on faisait
référence tout à l'heure pour le comité
du tourisme
alors qu'est ce qui dit le maire de fort
de france dans ce tweet puisqu'il est
difficile de travailler avec la ctm sur
les cofinancements européen de nos
projets il a pris la décision le maire
de fort-de-france de répondre désormais
directement aux appels à projets est
d'aller chercher lui même les
financements sans le filtre de certains
puits est lui bien bien je dis très bon
pas bien et l'on prend 2,2 voilà qui
passe par vous le même effort de free
face comme il veut d'accord parce que
même moi à mon niveau je dois mon os at
il de la collectivité territoriale
d'aller chercher des fonds européens
donc s'il a les capacités d'aller
chercher ces fonds européens
il a des porteurs de projets que nous ne
voyons pas forcément qu'ils l'aident ses
porteurs de projets sylla d'aider des
projets pourquoi il dit qu'il est
difficile de travailler jeunes
je ne vois pas à quoi il fait allusion
dans la mesure que tous les dossiers de
la ville de fort de france qui sont
présentés à la collectivité sont
budgétisées à hauteur de ce qu'ils
doivent
comment ça se passe à la cacem vous êtes
aussi en tant que conseillère municipale
de suite dans l'opposition mais vous
êtes conseillère communautaire
conseiller communauté à la casse m
ça se passe bien mieux qu'à fort de
france nous avons un dialogue nous
pouvons discuter bien que c'est un peu
la même équipe donc ne sont présents qu
en droit obligatoire et que
malheureusement nous n'avons pas
toujours l'oeil sur l'ensemble des
décisions mais nous participons de façon
active que nous sommes quand même dix
membres de l'ape ce que nous avons fait
un rassemblement de tous les élus delà
de la minorité pour avoir un projet
commun mais nous travaillons en symbiose
au niveau de la casse et vous continuer
à siéger aux conseils municipaux de fort
de france alors malheureusement je
déplore je ne puisse pas aller le plus
souvent mais ça se trouve que nous avons
réduit le nombre d'élus de la
collectivité
mais les instances qui nous réclame ont
même triplé
donc nous devons jongler quelquefois
nous avons des choix à faire des choix
stratégiques à faire malheureusement ça
tombe sur le conseil municipal qui
quelquefois change de date
quand on a pris les dispositions pour y
est il suffit d'un jour de changement on
ne peut pas toujours y est mais c'est
avec plaisir que je me rends chaque fois
que je peux y aller je vous suivez vous
continuez à suivre les affaires
foyalaise affaires municipales mais
comment on n'a pas eu de travail du
conseil municipal pour suivre les
affaires foyalaise d'autant plus que moi
je suis folle et alice
j'habite fort-de-france et les foyalais
n'hésite pas à m'interpeller alors il
n'y a pas un peu d'excès dans cette
appréciation de la situation de la part
de votre groupe
le groupe fox a changé faute france donc
un des groupes d'opposition c'est la
dernière question quand on quand ils
disent quand vous dites que fort de
france un endettement de 150 ans en
alors que la loi de finances mâcon
2018-2022 impose douze ans maximum en
faisant 150 ans et une totale réalité
c'est pas de l'excès c'est pas de
l'excès c'est une réalité
merci merci maman d'inès j'ai ma place
au journal bonne journée